Wizards of the Coast has been printing
commander-specific legendary creatures
since 2011—cards designed specifically to be
put in the command zone, rather than just being
creatures that happen to have the legendary tag.
As you might expect, these have not been without
controversy. Powerful designs like Yuriko
and Edgar Markov stretch the mechanics of
the commander format to its outer limit, and all
sorts of other cards are controversial in their
own right even if they’re less obvious mechanical
outliers. This month I want to talk about the
design and gameplay philosophy behind several
iconic but controversial commanders, specifically
whether they accomplished the goal of being
fun and dynamic gamepieces, or whether they’re
mistakes that should be avoided at all costs in
the future. I’ll get to some more controversial
options in later videos, but for now we’ll be
keeping things simple. I want to talk about Glass
Cannon commanders—commanders that are powerful and
explosive, but also fragile. More specifically,
I want to talk about how these cards, while
certainly having some benefits, can risk
misleading players and causing them to stumble
into play experiences they don’t necessarily want.
Something else that’s fragile, though, is your
Magic: The Gathering decks, which is why you
should consider some extremely cool-looking
accessories from this video’s sponsor,
Voidmonster. Voidmonster is run by Magic: The
Gathering artist Forrest Imel, and features
some pretty fantastic original designs. The color
playmats are a great evergreen option, and there’s
also a new drop every month available for only
a limited time. This month is the Devoid drop,
which includes a playmat, a deck box, and a bonus
mana tracker card if you buy the bundle. I love
the sort of chalky, austere exterior paired with
the writhing blue tentacles on the interior—this
perfectly encapsulates Eldrazi to me. If this
drop interests you, you can follow the link in
my description and preorder before October 19th.
Thanks to Voidmonster for sponsoring the video.
Okay, so glass cannon commanders. There are plenty
of recent commanders that fit this description,
and I’ll get to one of the most infamous
examples of this in a little while,
but for now we need to dig into the origins of
this sort of design by discussing the first ever
commander set. Commander 2011 was a set that was
quite experimental and out-there for the time,
and there are a lot of things here I could
talk about—the poor-by-present-day-standards
construction of the precons, the reprinting
of the ultimately-banned Trade Secrets, some
intriguing early attempts at political tools seen
in the Jeskai deck, and other assorted oddities.
This set also contains a lot of interesting
early attempts at commander-first designs,
legendary creatures designed specifically with the
intent of being commanders, and with designs that
fit their intended role as a centerpiece creature.
Of the commanders in this set, two have really
stood the test of time—Kaalia of the Vast, and
Animar Soul of the Elements. Sitting at #5 and
#29 most popular among all commanders at present
day, respectively, these have endured as potent
designs in a way that other commander options
from the set like Ghave and Riku simply could
not. And this makes sense—far from being crowded
out by any old graveyards or tokens or spell-copy
commander, these two are unique and embody their
playstyles in a way that’s difficult to replicate.
Take Kaalia—she’s a 4 mana 2/2 flier in Mardu
colors who lets her controller put into play
an angel, demon, or dragon tapped and attacking
whenever she attacks. The merging of these three
big flying creature types associated with three
different colors is quite iconic and specific
to Kaalia, and though her creature-cheating
functionality shares some similarities with
more recent designs like Akul the Unrepetent
and Mr. Foxglove, no other card accomplishes
this cheating quite the way Kaalia does. The same
goes for Animar—though there are other cards that
can provide deep discounts for creature spells,
such as Rakdos and Hamza, these generally require
a bit more specificity in their play patterns to
pay off big. Animar, on the other hand, is a fully
pre-assembled creature storm machine—the only step
to making creatures cheaper is casting creatures,
and it’s not hard to see how this could lead to
some dramatic turns without much setup required.
In short, both of these commanders have a specific
and iconic niche that they embody quite well. This
is one part of their popularity, and the
other is simply that they’re efficient at
their role. Each of these cards has a high
ceiling, and achieving a powerful gamestate
doesn’t require as many steps as with a lot
of other commanders, simply requiring having
cards in hand ready to deploy and avoiding
opposing removal. But, what about the floor?
The biggest weakness of these two commanders
is that their gameplans are a bit brittle,
and not particularly hard to set back to
basically square one. To fully get into
why I’d apply a label like “glass cannon” to
these, we should really discuss the nature
of what commanders provide for various decks.
Fundamentally, all commanders will be an enabler,
a payoff, or something in between.
Payoffs are the most common—Isshin
doubles on-attack triggers, amplifying the
volume of gameplay produced by cards with these,
and Atraxa gives proliferates which amplify the
power of cards that use counters. These feel nice
to play because the play pattern is simple
and effective—you start putting together a
gameplan with cards the commander synergizes
with, and then you drop the commander after
a bit to turbo-charge that gameplan.
Enabler commanders are less common—Zur
the Enchanter is the only card in the top 100
commanders I’d call a “pure enabler”, as he isn’t
really a payoff for anything at all, aside from
maybe having a pair of lightning greaves and some
cool enchantments to grab in library. You play
him so you can start tutoring out enchantments,
and then your gameplan gets built from there.
This end of things is closer to where Animar
and Kaalia live, with Animar being a slight
enabler and Kaalia being a moderate enabler.
On a basic level, being an enabler isn’t a bad
thing—my favorite decks feature commanders that
fall closer to the enabling end of the
spectrum. However, enabler commanders
are inherently trickier to make play well
because of the nature of the enabler-payoff
relationship. Whereas a payoff commander is
the amplifying adornment atop a solid 99,
an enabler commander will a lot of times
be step 1 to doing anything in the game,
with the rest of the deck living atop it.
To be clear, this isn’t always a problem.
If there are other ways to get the enabling
component, it can be fine. If the enabling
component is hard to prevent or set back, it
can be fine. And, if the enabling component
isn’t essential to the deck’s functionality,
it can be fine. The issue should hopefully be
becoming clearer—these caveats go frequently
unfulfilled with each of these commanders.
Kaalia of the Vast’s role is to cheat permanents
into play, and she’s generally an important
enabler for the big-flying-creatures gameplans
she’s played with. Can the deck do its gameplan
without her? Not really—the average Kaalia
deck has 36 lands and 11 pieces of ramp in it,
numbers far too small for a deck with an average
mana value over 4. Next you might ask, can it at
least protect her? And the answer is kind of—hasty
boots are golden here, and you certainly can add
other cards that can protect Kaalia early such
as Mother of Runes or Deflecting Swat. However,
this is complicated by the fact that the
deck is also vulnerable to board wipes,
since it’s a low-velocity big creature midrange
deck, so ideally your protection suite can help
out with that as well. This might allude to the
fundamental challenge with building Kaalia—deck
space. Ideally the deck will want some single
target protection to deal with early pinpoint
removal, as well as some board protection and
a healthy draw suite to let it manage wipes,
plus a healthy count of lands and ramp to
help the deck bounce back from all challenges.
Going higher on the counts of all of these could
let the deck feel more flexible and resilient,
but also risks removing some of the bite of
the deck. As the count of Angels, Demons,
and Dragons dips lower to offer other things to
the deck, the aggressive options to choose from
for Kaalia triggers will also typically dip, and
you’ll run out of creatures to cheat out earlier
and more often. It’s no surprise, then, that a lot
of Kaalia players take the opposite approach—lower
land counts, lower protection counts, focusing
on powerful beaters rather than card draw,
even including amplifier permanents like Isshin
and Windcrag Siege that can further pump up the
explosiveness of the deck. Why play some neutered,
halfway consistent Kaalia deck when you can live
your most daring Mardu fantasies, to stray
ever closer to the sun with your cool fliers.
On the surface, Animar might seem quite a bit
different from this. It’s typically more reliant
on early draws to start presenting a threat at
the table, but its relationship with opposing
interaction is arguably less problematic. At worst
you’ll empty your hand into a board wipe and lose
a bunch of resources, but unlike with Kaalia the
99 typically features a decent amount of draw
and ramp, allowing for smoother recoveries. At
best Animar can turn a deck into a high-velocity
machine—even without an Ancestral Statue infinite
combo, with the right draw engines, ramp engines,
and maybe a haste enabler, you can empty a hefty
portion of your deck onto the board in a single
turn, possibly deleting an opponent in the process
if you can swing or get some Terror of the Peaks
triggers. The commander also has at least a bit
of built in protection as well, unlike Kaalia,
dodging about half of all popular pinpoint
removal. So, there certainly are differences
between these. Where these commanders are
similar, though, is in their power profile,
and in the difference between the floor and
ceiling of their gameplan. Due to the fact
that both of these commanders are enablers that
discount large amounts of mana on creatures,
in the most ideal games with the best draws
and the least opposing interaction, they’re
exploding out of control. Meanwhile, if draws are
worse, particularly for Animar, or if there’s more
interaction, particularly for Kaalia, the function
of discounting creature spells isn’t as helpful.
Quite a lot of commanders feature the phrase “draw
a card” or some equivalent in their text box,
and while you could argue that generic value is
a little overplayed as a payoff for a commander
to grant, this choice has had the undeniable
boon of improving the resilience of a lot of
playstyles. The commander of a deck is a card
that’s available at all times, and assuming
the draw condition isn’t too hard, having that
permanent 8th card in hand be a draw spell reduces
the risk of stallouts and improves recovery.
If you need to hit land drops, drawing cards
can find you lands. If you’re looking for specific
synergy pieces, drawing cards can get you closer
to those as well. If you just got board wiped, as
long as you drew some cards before that happened,
you hopefully have some options for rebuilding.
A value engine commander typically won’t be the
most threatening or aggressive choice, but it
will usually be a safer and more consistent one,
all things equal. Your command zone secures
you exactly one single element of your deck,
and though you can try to sculpt your 99
to lead to a well-balanced experience,
there will still only be one card in your
deck that you’re absolutely guaranteed to
see. This is why the most explosive decks
out there typically feature an explosive
commander focused on either damage or raw
board size, and a pretty infamous example
of this that I’d also apply the glass
cannon label to is Jodah, the Unifier.
Jodah is a five-color commander that gives
your legendaries +X/+X where X is the number
of legendary creatures you control, and who
also gives your legendary spells you cast
from hand legendary-cascade. Unlike the
commanders from 2011 I discussed earlier,
this card is closer to the payoff end of the
enabler-payoff spectrum. However, it ends up
fitting a similar profile to those other two due
to how absurdly efficient it is at one specific
task—getting power and toughness onto board.
The two lines of text on the card can combine
to create utterly monstrous boards of legendary
creatures in one or two turns, and passing the
turn to a player who has Jodah on the field feels
like rolling the dice on whether or not you take
lethal combat damage this turn. For this reason,
Jodah tends to eat removal like few others, being
more or less a kill-on-sight commander at most
tables alongside other powerhouses like Winota or
Tergrid. This might be fine if you’re prepared for
it, and you could even do what my brother did and
engineer your Jodah deck to have almost constant
access to protective cards in place of a bit of
explosiveness. But an unknowing player who throws
together a Jodah deck and expects to be able to
assemble an army of 9 12/12s in peace might have
a rude awakening when they pull up to a table and
have their commander reacted to appropriately.
This points to the biggest critique I’d lodge at
the glass-cannon-iest of commanders, the ones
with the highest ratio of explosive power to
resilience. They act like a sort of bait,
attracting players who are understandably
seeking out big, exciting plays and then putting
these players in situations where their opponents
have few choices but to bully their deck’s
terrifying commander off the field repeatedly.
All of this might feel like a hit piece
on these sorts of glass cannon commanders,
and maybe even all commanders that lean
more explosive and/or fragile. However,
I don’t want this video to be misread as saying
that these decks shouldn’t be played or have no
redeeming qualities. There is an allure to playing
a deck that gets going fast, that does something
opponents find scary, and that forces the table
to wake up, even if it doesn’t recover well.
Part of the appeal is that it puts a strong
emphasis on the early and mid-game, almost
serving as a test for how long a player can extend
this period and how much explosive power they can
pack into that. My most powerful deck doesn’t
really have a lategame plan, and though this
can mean being less relevant in a game that goes
that far, it also means that mid game turns are
far more exciting and rich in decisionmaking for
me, which can be a lot of fun. As another example
that’s even more emblematic of this philosophy,
I played several games with a Breena deck at
MagicCon Atlanta recently. In my games against
a mixture of high bracket 3 and low bracket
4 decks, I’d typically get off to a strong and
attention-grabbing start, with several creatures
loaded up with +1/+1 counters and swinging in big
at opponents, but each game I’d inevitably get my
board whittled down and see my gameplan start
to stall out. I lost every game, but in every
game it felt like I had a shot at winning, and
each game also had an interesting narrative arc
that I played a major role in. I was the villain,
the biggest baddest deck around on turn 5, and I
was usually able to smack away half the collective
health of my opponents before my eventual decline.
I didn’t win those games, but I sure played
a lot of Magic the Gathering during them.
Really, the takeaway here is not to not play
glass cannon decks or glass cannon commanders,
but rather to know when you’re playing these sorts
of commanders and to make an active decision about
whether that’s what you want to be doing. I would
argue that Kaalia makes for a kinda bad precon
commander for the same reason I wouldn’t hand
a Jodah deck to a newer player—because I don’t
think a glass cannon commander is going to produce
consistently good play experiences for somebody
just getting into the game. It can provide a
tantalizing taste of explosive gameplay with big,
cool-looking creatures, but it’s just as likely
to produce frustration when the Kaalia player
eats a bunch of interaction and stalls out for a
while. This is not to say that a zanier or spicier
commander is never the correct choice for a newer
player, and I’m sure there are plenty of players
who had a blast getting into EDH with a Kaalia
deck, but I personally would shoot closer to the
middle of the explosive-resilient spectrum and let
players find their own way to the spiciest brews.
This is also why I’m of the opinion that Pantlaza
getting printed was the best thing to happen to
Dinosaur decks in the past 5 years. This is the
quintessential Timmy tribe and for years the
primary commander for Naya dinos was Gishath, an
explosive-but-fragile 8 mana enabler commander. On
the one hand I’m sure this is a very exciting card
to have in the command zone for a lot of players,
but in practice I’ve seen it mostly serve to
make the big creature decks it helms feel even
swingier, and fall even flatter in the face of
interaction. Seeing a Gishath player sitting
there waiting for a 10th or 12th or 14th
land drop is a pretty common occurrence,
and one that I have to imagine isn’t a lot
of fun for somebody newer to the commander
format. Meanwhile, swapping Gishath out for
Pantlaza, a 5 mana engine card that often
finds value or ramp off its triggers,
makes most decks feel much smoother,
and also less punishing of suboptimal
choices made in the deckbuilding process.
Playing Gishath still remains a spicy option for
any dino enjoyers looking to play with fire a bit,
as it should be, but it’s good that it’s no longer
the default choice for all Dinosaur players.
One final thing it’s worth talking about is
how to know when a commander falls into that
sort of glass cannon classification.
There isn’t an exact description,
but these are a few attributes to keep an eye out
for, in descending order of glass-cannon-y-ness.
1. Decks with the commander struggle to hold
onto gained resources through setbacks. Most
decks that are having an explosive
sequence of turns will gain mana,
draw cards, set up permanents of various types,
and use other zones to solidify their advantage
into the longer game if they can’t figure out
how to win on the spot. If you’re way ahead
and either half of a Cleansing Nova causes
you to lose basically all of that advantage,
you’re playing a glass cannon deck, and your
commander might be glass cannon commander.
2. The commander plays an essential role in the
deck, and has few to no replacements within the
deck. If your commander fills an important task
and you don’t have great ways of accomplishing
that task with any other cards, you’re
putting a lot of pressure on them to
stay alive, and much of your deck’s power is
concentrated into a single point of failure.
3. The difference between the deck’s ceiling
and floor is dramatic. Instead of floor and
ceiling you could think about the deck’s 80th
percentile game vs the deck’s 20th percentile
game—if the 80th percentile game sees the
deck exploding out of control and the 20th
percentile game sees the deck floundering, you’re
looking at an inconsistent deck if nothing else.
If these describe a commander or deck you’re
interested in, it doesn’t mean you shouldn’t
play it. You should, however, think about
whether these attributes are going to create
a good experience for you, and if you do choose
to build the deck these are some things to keep
in the back of your mind as things to mitigate
if you find stallouts unfun. Commander choice,
as with most things in EDH, is a decision
best made with intentionality—know
what you’re getting into, and you’ll
have more fun in the games to come.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt for
supporting the channel. Archidekt’s nice UI and
flexible category system make me happy to spend
way too much time brewing random nonsense. A link
to my decks is in the description. I also want to
thank my supporters on Patreon and YouTube, some
of whom are onscreen now. Both my Patrons and my
YouTube members get bonus videos whenever I feel
like making them, usually about one a month, and
I’m also taking submissions for my fall supporter
deck review. If any of that sounds interesting to
you, a link to my Patreon is in the description.